là où j'ai grandi c'était un monde
différent de celui ci mon père il était
d'une autre époque tu vois comment il
était très religieux non lillois partent
plutôt superstitieux alors qu'est ce que
vous voulez faire dans les parages c'est
l'enterrement de mon père
il voit pas beaucoup d'inconnues par là
haut
[Musique]
l'intérieur
je sais vous étiez en avion et s'est
écrasé
puis devenu ma famille
[Musique]
mon amie on a pu retrouver que vous
une fois une ambiance y a pas d'hopital
à moins de 80 km où vous croyez que vous
êtes à new york peut-être
ça
c'est une effigie de vous tout ce qui
lui arrive
vous arrive à vous
je vais vous soigner je vais bien vous
soigner
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant dis nous ce que tu vois
vous vivez peut-être en ville mais vous
avez grandi ici
je place de grands espoirs en vous
[Musique]
j'aime ma famille
elle fait ce qu'elle veut de qu'il veut
j'adore mes débuts
je tenais à terre
[Musique]
c'est pour votre bien